comment ça va t'aider à isaac ça va ils
sont hors de mon crâne c'est le seul
problème des nouvelles de monica n'ont
pas la moindre même par texto genre
j'espère que tu vas bien pour un seul je
la déteste l'idée en gaz n aurait pas un
peu de fric sur toi elle est là juste
devant tu mon fils à asa grace munitions
allez c'est parti
conçu en tirer ouais quoi ça y est
maintenant je me suis père izzy côté du
lait ça fait du bien
bonjour vous êtes la mère de monica oui
c'est moi en jambes dame
le truc c'est god fille a commis une
grave injustice alors nous on est venu
pour se venger en quelque sorte
peut-être qu'on paye pas de mine comme
ça parce qu à nous trois on n'a que 5
jambes de paires d'yeux et quatre
poumons et demie mais nous disposons
également de deux douzaines d'oeufs
alors si j'étais vous j'irais m'abriter
à l'intérieur